Good morning, everyone. How's it going, bros?
I am in Japan, and today is vlog day. Smash like for vlog day if you're excited.
Today we're going to Kamakura,
which I've been to once before. We're gonna recreate the vlog step by step starting now
*music*
So for those of you who don't know,
Kamakura is about an hour away from Tokyo. South. It's like a beach town
I would say. We're not actually recreating the vlog. Goddamn it's windy. We're just exploring
what we haven't done before like making strawberries and the bamboo forest, which I really want to see.
The
strawberry place is closed, but we have ice cream.
So, cheers. There's that. It's like matcha green tea flavor.
*disgusted noise*
I don't know if I like it.
We're about to go to the same bike rental.
We're about halfway there. So far we haven't died. I forgot how pretty Kamakura is. It's so *unintelligible* like.
It's pretty, okay. It's pretty.
We got giant fishies, yo. Oh, I totally missed the zoomin. There you are! Found you.
Marzia: I didn't even see it!
Felix: Yeah. See em'?
Marzia: No.
Felix: *as the fish* Aww, you didn't see me Marzia? *unintelligible*
We made it to the bamboo forest.
Surprisingly lack of bamboo. Is this not the bamboo forest? Wow. Whoa.
I'm starting to think this is not the bamboo forest, and it's just a forest.
She only understands this. *hand gestures in Italian*
Pasta over there.
Wow
So pretty
Look at this tree!
I'm feeling nihongo (Japanese language) as **** right now. Nihon (Japan), I mean.
Of course, nihongo means language. I knew that.
(Of course you did, Felix)
Edit that out, Marzia.
*heavy breathing* Please.
*gasps* That's a little guy with a hat down there.
I'm so glad I'm sharing this moment with Marzia.
Who's not here...
So they're not in full bloom, but it's getting there.
This is a real Japanese moment, guys.
This was worth the trip. Just this tree. What a forest of bamboo. There's so many of them
Very nice.
That is so cute.
Why does he have a *unintelligible* (probably Swedish)?
Okay, this is the real deal. Whoa!
Holy
Damn
That's some bamboo boy. Whoa!
Amazing. I like them big. I like them chunky. Good joke, Felix. Thank you. Please don't copyright.
Whoa, something just fell.
Whew
A lot of people don't know this, but if you knock on a really big bamboo, special sound will come out.
*knock*
You hear that?
*sound of Logan Paul saying "Yup!" from suicide forest video*
Amazing
What a day -- what a time to be alive
What a time to be a youtuber, everyone.
We decided we're gonna go to the center and check out
*unintelligible* Did you just *bike bell noises*?
I remember buying honey in Kamakura.
That was so good. The goal is to find it again. Do you remember that Marzia?
Marzia said yes, in case anyone's asking.
This vlog will not get any more interesting in this
Just letting you guys know *chuckles*
We're going to get honey, guys
Minion flavor
What does a minion taste like?
What are you doing?
Oh my god. We found another one.
Look at this.
So it's basically flavored honey.
*big yum noises*
*small dink*
Mmmm! That's so good! You never think [of] drinking honey, but it's so good.
Goin' in raw
*more yum noises*
Oishi (delicious).
(Felix flexin his nihongo knowledge)
Mmm, it's really good, but not as good as G Fuel...
(use code pewdiepie)
Nice and cozy. (We're on?) the subway.
We're almost back home.
I don't know why I'm filming this.
We made it back everyone! Hello!
Hello.
Hope you enjoyed this very fun day. Very nice.
Not the most eventful. Shame about the strawberries or should I say ichigo (strawberries in Japanese)?
(Picking?)
For those who are wondering. *clears throat* This is how my setup looks like while I'm here.
Thank you Origin PC! The laptop, actually, it very handy *laughs*
I literally did a sponsor with them and they were like, "If you bring your setup anywhere,
it's very good," and it is. Thank you.
I love how I can just bring this set up anywhere and just record. It's so cool. I'm very --   I'm very happy
I honestly can't believe this is happening. People are making fun of me for my height. Can you believe this?
Can you believe people doing this? I'm 180
Also Felix wearing shoes. You're making fun of my shoes!?
I am so tall, and I'm not insecure by my height, and I'm gonna prove once and for all
If I'm not a 180 then how come --
How come it says on my passport?
180 huh? Can you see that?
Point proven, incels
Try again you manlets. 180 is peak height by the way. Right, Marzia?
*Marzia noise*
She says yes.
Anything above 180 and you look like you have something to prove, but you don't
Anything less you look like a tiny little frog, okay? 180 guys if you're 180, let me know in the comments
because we need to stand together against this abuse that I will not stand for anymore,
which I can't cuz I don't have legs. How is this meme still going up. It's time to end this vlog, and uhh..
See you guys on the flip side. That's my outro ghost
flip-flopping
Flippity-flop next time
*boop*
Darkness then redness then whiteness.
Dooone and boop!
Hey, how about that! This boring vlog isn't over - Marzia's been editing it and we review the footage and we're like...
Nothing really happened. I also realized how
monotone I was like in my vlog and prior to my videos. This is how I actually am as a person, guys.
Hope you enjoy it. We're doing it, guys. We're doing the famous crossing, and we have to hurry up or anything
So cool.
All right we're going in here. Oh Jesus, why do they have fish over there? Oh my god [it's] the Eels
That's amazing.
What?
What is this shot?
Jesus Christ, Japan, what is wrong with you? Oh my god
Attack on Titan laundry detergent. Seriously?
Wow it looks... just like Hachiko... *laughs*
Very a-- Whoa, Jesus! Oh my god. What has happened?
That was bad it's fine.
This shop is uh..
interesting *laughs*
Very nice
This shop has so many cool
figures, but they're so expensive *laughs*
Hey, it's boob man. You know him
It's a shark
that is also a
transformer
amazing
vintage devil man
Pretty cool. Hey, I'm a blue-eyes white dragon, while you just dark magician. No wait, there it is
Nailed it
I think this is one of the cards they censor in the West. This one
because it has boobs. Can't have that in the West. That's honestly dope. I'm kind of tempted to buy that. What is this?
Together maybe
(hot)
This is T-series
We're here at Meguro River
They got the lanterns lit, and there's supposed to be cherry blossom. I have an Android. It's really good camera
Yeah, because it's an Android it's really good camera
Androids have -- Androids have the best camera. I'm really glad we came at night because you can really see everything
*music*
Nighttime sakura everyone. Sugoi desu, ne?
(Amazing, isn't it?)
Whoa
They're everywhere
Hope this
extra bonus part of the vlog made up for it.
Very exciting launch. Changing the game instead of making them super fun and exi--
Oh my god. What is that?
*Marzia laughs* What the h***?
Hope you guys enjoyed this vlog. Hope you guys c--
enjoyed coming along. How do I vlog it completely forgot how you do it.
Smash like,
Subscribe. We can still be t-series or something like that. Goodbye, sayonara. Bye. Bye.